Sigmund Freud I embarked on the
adventure of my intellectual development
by becoming a psychiatrist as early as
1900 I had read Freud's the
interpretation of dreams I'd laid the
book aside at the time because I did not
yet grasp it at the age of 25 I lacked
the experience to appreciate Freud's
theories such experience did not come
until later in 1903 I once more took up
for the interpretation of Dreams and
discovered how it all linked up with my
own ideas but chiefly interested me was
the application to dreams of the concept
of the repression mechanism which was
derived from the psychology of neuroses
this was important to me because I had
frequently encountered repressions in my
experiments with word association in
response to certain stimulus words the
patient either had no associative answer
or was unduly slow in his reaction time
as was later discovered such a
disturbance occurred each time the
stimulus word had touched upon a psychic
lesion or conflict in most cases the
patient was unconscious of this when
questioned about the cause of the
disturbance he would often answer in a
peculiarly artificial manner my reading
of Freud's the interpretation of Dreams
showed me that the repression mechanism
was at work here and that the facts I
had observed but consonant with his
theory thus I was able to corroborate
Freud's line of argument the situation
was different when it came to the
content of the repression here I could
not agree with Freud he considered the
cause of the repression to be a sexual
trauma from my practice however I was
familiar with numerous cases of neurosis
in which the question of sexuality
played a subordinate part are the
factors standing in the foreground for
example the problem of social adaptation
of oppression by tragic circumstances of
life prestige considerations and so on
later I presented such cases to Freud
but he would not grant the
factors other than sexuality could be
the cause that was highly unsatisfactory
to me at the beginning it was not easy
for me to assign Freud the proper place
in my life or to take the right attitude
toward him when I became acquainted with
his work I was planning an academic
career and was about to complete a paper
that was intended to advance me at the
University but Freud was definitely
persona non grata in the academic world
at the time and any connection with him
would have been damaging in scientific
circles important people at most
mentioned him surreptitiously and at
congress's he was discussed only in the
corridors never on the floor therefore
the discovery that my association
experiments were in agreement with
Freud's theories was far from pleasant
to me once while I was in my laboratory
and reflecting again upon these
questions the devil whispered to me that
I would be justified in publishing the
results of my experiments and my
conclusions without mentioning Freud but
then I heard the voice of my second
personality you cannot build your life
upon a lie with that the question was
settled from then on
I became an open partisan of Freud's and
fought for him I first took up the
cudgels for Freud at a Congress in
Munich where a lecturer discussed
obsessional neuroses but studiously
forbore to mention the name of Freud in
1906 in connection with his incident I
wrote a paper on Freud's theory of the
neurosis which had contributed a great
deal to the understanding of obsessional
neurosis in response to this article two
German professors wrote to me warning
that if I remained on Freud's side and
continued to defend him I would be
endangering my academic career I replied
if what Freud says is the truth I am
with him I don't give a damn for a
career if it has to be based on the
premise of restricting research and
concealing truth and I went on defending
Freud and his ideas but on the basis of
my own findings
I was still unable to feel that all
neuroses were caused by sexual
repression or sexual trauma in certain
cases that was so but not in others
nevertheless Freud had opened up a new
path of Investigation and the shocked
out cries against him at the time seemed
to me absurd I had not met with much
sympathy for the ideas expressed in the
psychology of dementia praecox in fact
my colleagues laughed at me but through
this book I came to know Freud he
invited me to visit him and our first
meeting took place in Vienna in March
1907 we met at one o'clock in the
afternoon and talked virtually without a
pause for thirteen hours
Freud was the first man of real
importance I had encountered in my
experience after that time no one else
could compare with him there was nothing
the least trivial in his attitude I
found him extremely intelligent shrewd
and altogether remarkable and yet my
first impressions of him remained
somewhat tangled I could not make him
out above all Freud's attitude toward
the spirit seemed to me highly
questionable wherever in a person or in
a work of art an expression of
spirituality came to light he suspected
it and insinuated that it was repressed
sexuality anything that could not be
directly interpreted as sexuality he
referred to as psycho sexuality I
protested that this hypothesis carried
to its logical conclusion would lead to
an annihilating judgment upon culture
culture would then appear as a mere
farce the morbid consequence of
repressed sexuality yes he assented so
it is and that is just a curse of fate
against which we are powerless to
contend I was by no means disposed to
agree or to let it go at that
but still I did not feel competent to
argue it out with him I can still recall
vividly how Freud said to me my dear
young promised me never to abandon the
sexual theory that is the most essential
thing of all you see we must make a
dogma
of it an unshakable bulwark he said that
to me with great emotion in the tone of
a father saying and promise me this one
thing my dear son that you will go to
church every Sunday in some astonishment
I asked him a bollock against what to
which he replied against the black tide
of mud and here he hesitated a moment
then added of occultism first of all it
was the word bulwark and Dogma that
alarmed me for a Dogma that is to say an
undisputable confession of faith is set
up only when the aim is to suppress
doubts once and for all but that no
longer has anything to do with
scientific judgment only with a personal
power drive this was the thing that
struck at the heart of our friendship I
knew I would never be able to accept
such an attitude although I did not
properly understand it then I had
observed in Freud the eruption of
unconscious religious factors evidently
he wanted my aid in erecting a barrier
against these threatening unconscious
contents I was bewildered and
embarrassed I had the feeling that I had
caught a glimpse of a new unknown
country from which swarms of new ideas
flew to meet me one thing was clear
Freud would always made much of his
religiosity had now constructed a Dogma
or other in the place of a jealous God
whom he had lost
he had substituted another compelling
image that of sexuality it was no less
insistent exacting domineering
threatening and morally ambivalent than
the original one just as the psychically
stronger agency is given divine or
demonic attributes so the sexual libido
took over the role of a hidden or
concealed God the advantage of this
transformation for Freud was apparently
that he was able to regard the new
numinous principle as scientifically
irreproachable and free from all
religious ain't at bottom however the
numerosity
that is the psychological qualities of
the two rational
incommensurable opposites Yahweh and
sexuality remain the same the name alone
had changed and with it of course the
point of view the lost guard had now to
be sought below not above like flames
suddenly flaring up these thoughts
darted through my mind much later when I
reflected upon Freud's character they
revealed their significance there was
one characteristic of his that
preoccupied me above all his bitterness
Freud never asked himself why he was
compelled to talk continually of sex why
this idea had taken such possession of
him he remained unaware that his
monotony of interpretation expressed a
flight from himself or from that other
side of him which might perhaps be
called mystical so long as he refused to
acknowledge that side he could never be
reconciled with himself he was blind
toward the paradox and ambiguity of the
contents of the unconscious and did not
know that everything which arises out of
the unconscious has a top and a bottom
an inside and an outside when we speak
of the outside and that is what Freud
did we are considering only half of the
whole with a result that a counter
effect arises out of the unconscious
there was nothing to be done about this
one sightedness of Freud's perhaps some
inner experience of his own might have
opened his eyes but then his intellect
would have reduced such experience to
mere sexuality or psycho sexuality he
remained the victim of the one aspect he
could recognize and for that reason I
see him as a tragic figure for he was a
great man and what is more a man in the
grip of his diamond the year 1909 proved
decisive for our relationship I've been
invited to lecture on the Association
experiment at Clark University in
Worcester Massachusetts independently
Freud had also received an invitation
and we decided to travel together we met
in Bremen where Firenze he joined us
in Bremen a much discussed incident of
Freud's fainting fit occurred it was
provoked indirectly by my interest in
the peat bog corpses I knew that in
certain districts of northern Germany
these so-called bog corpses were to be
found
they are the bodies of prehistoric men
who either drowned in the marshes or
buried there the bog water in which the
bodies lie contains humic acid which
consumes the bones and simultaneously
tans the skin so that it and the hair
are perfectly preserved in essence this
is the process of natural mummification
this interest of mine got on Freud's
nerves why are you so concerned with
these corpses he asked me several times
he was inordinately vexed by the whole
thing and during one such conversation
while we were having dinner together
he suddenly fainted afterward he said to
me that he was convinced that all this
chatter about corpses meant I had death
wishes toward him I was more than
surprised by this interpretation I was
alarmed by the intensity of his
fantasies so strong that obviously they
could cause him to faint in a similar
connection Freud once more suffered a
fainting fit in my presence this was
during the psychoanalytic Congress in
Munich in 1912 someone had turned the
conversation to the Egyptian king
McNaughton the point was made that as a
result of his negative attitude toward
his father he had destroyed his father's
cartouche is on the stainless and that
of back of his great creation of
monotheistic religion they left a father
complex at that moment
Freud slid off his chair in a faint
everyone clustered helplessly around him
I picked him up carried him into the
next room and laid him on a sofa as I
was carrying him he half came to and I
shall never forget the look he casted me
in his weakness he looked at me as if I
were his father whatever other causes
may have contributed to this faint the
atmosphere was very tense the fantasy of
father meadow
at the time Freud frequently made
allusions indicating that he regarded me
as his successor these hints were
embarrassing to me in the first place
that sort of thing was not in my nature
in the second place I could not
sacrifice my intellectual independence
and in the third place such lustre was
highly unwelcome to me since it would
only deflect from my real aims
I was concerned with investigating truth
not with questions of personal prestige
the trip to the United States which
began in Bremen in 1909 lasted for seven
weeks we were together every day and
analyzed each other's dreams I regarded
Freud as an older more mature and
experienced personality and felt like a
son in that respect but then something
happened which proved to be a severe
blow to the whole relationship Freud had
a dream I would not think it right to
air the problem it involved I
interpreted it as best I could but added
that a great deal more could be said
about it if he would supply me with some
additional details from his private life
Freud's response to these words was a
curious look a look of the utmost
suspicion then he said but I cannot risk
my authority at that moment he lost it
altogether
that sentence burned itself into my
memory and in it the end of our
relationship was already foreshadowed
Freud was placing personal authority
over truth
Freud was able to interpret the dreams I
was then having only in completely or
not at all one in particular was
important to me for it led me for the
first time to the concept of the
collective unconscious and thus formed a
kind of prelude to my book symbols of
transformation this was the dream I was
in a house I did not know which had two
stories it was my house I found myself
in the upper storey where there was a
kind of cellar furnished with fine old
pieces in Rococo style descending the
stairs I reached the ground floor
there everything was much older and I
realized that this part of the house
must date from about the 15th or 16th
century the furnishings were medieval I
came upon a heavy door and opened it
beyond it I discovered a stone stairway
that led down into the cellar descending
again I found myself in a beautifully
vaulted room which looked exceedingly
ancient I discovered layers of brick
among the ordinary stone blocks and
chips of brick in the mortar as soon as
I saw this I knew that the walls dated
from Roman times by interest by now was
intense I looked more closely at the
floor it was of stone slabs and in one
of these I discovered a ring when I
pulled it the stone slab lifted and
again I saw a stairway of narrow stone
steps leading down into the depths these
two I descended and entered a low cave
cut into the rock thick dust lay on the
floor and in the dust were scattered
bones and broken pottery like remains of
a primitive culture I discovered two
human skulls obviously very old and half
disintegrated then I awoke what chiefly
interested Freud in this dream were the
two skulls he returned to them
repeatedly and urged me to find a wish
in connection with him what did I think
about these scales and whose were they
I knew perfectly well of course what he
was driving at but secret death wishes
were concealed in the dream but what
does he really expect of me I thought to
myself toward whom but I have death
wishes
I felt violent resistance to any such
interpretation I also had some
intimation of what the dream might
really mean but I did not then trust my
own judgment and wanted to hear fraud's
opinion I wanted to learn from him
therefore I submitted to his intention
and said my wife and sister-in-law and
so I told him a lie
it was plain to me that the house
represented a kind of image of a psyche
that is to say of my then state of
consciousness with hitherto unconscious
Editions consciousness was represented
by the cell
it had an inhabited atmosphere in spite
of its antiquated style the ground floor
stood for the first level of the
unconscious the deeper I went the more
alien and the darker the scene became in
the cave I discovered remains of a
primitive culture that is the world of
the primitive man within myself a world
which can scarcely be reached or
illuminated by consciousness the
primitive psyche of man borders on the
life of the animals so just as the caves
of prehistoric times were usually
inhabited by animals before men laid
claim to them certain questions have
been much on my mind during the days
preceding this dream on what premises is
Freudian psychology founded to what
category of human thought does it belong
what is the relationship of its almost
exclusive personalism to general
historical assumptions my dream was
giving me the answer it obviously
pointed to the foundations of cultural
history a history of successive layers
of consciousness my dream thus
constituted a kind of structural diagram
of the human psyche it postulated
something of an altogether impersonal
nature underlying that psyche it clicked
as the English habit and the dream
became for me a guiding image which in
the days to come was to be corroborated
to an extent I could not at first
suspect it was my first inkling of a
collective a priori beneath the personal
psyche this I first took to be the
traces of earlier modes of functioning
later with increasing experience and on
the basis of more reliable knowledge I
recognized them as forms of instinct
that is as archetypes the dream of the
house had a curious effect of
on me it revived my old interest in
archeology I read like mad and worked
with feverish interest through a
mountain of mythological material then
through the Gnostic writers and ended in
total confusion It was as if I were in
an imaginary madhouse and were beginning
to treat and analyze all the Santa's
nymphs gods and goddesses as though they
were my patients while thus occupied I
could not help but discover the close
relationship between ancient mythology
and the psychology of primitive people
and this led me to an intensive study of
the latter under the impress of Freud's
personality I had as far as possible
cast aside my own judgments and
repressed my criticisms that was the
prerequisite for collaborating with him
but a me was a profound disappointment
that all the efforts of the probing mind
had apparently succeeded in finding
nothing more in the depth of the psyche
than the all-too-familiar
and all to human limitations I had grown
up in the country among peasants and
what I was unable to learn in the
stables I found out from the rabble
Asian wit and untrammeled fantasies of
our peasant folklore incest and
perversions are not remarkable novelties
to me and did not call for any special
explanation
along with criminality they formed part
of the Black Lee's that spoiled the
taste of life by showing me only too
plainly the ugliness and meaninglessness
of human existence that cabbages thrive
in dung was something I had always taken
for granted nor honesty I could discover
no helpful insight in such knowledge
it's just that all of those people are
city folks who know nothing about nature
and the humans stable I thought sick and
tired of these ugly matters one form of
life cannot simply be abandoned unless
it is exchanged for another as
for a totally rational approach to life
that is as experience shows impossible
especially when a person is by nature as
unreasonable as a neurotic I now
realized why Freud's personal psychology
was of such burning interest to me I was
eager to know the truth about his
reasonable solution and I was prepared
to sacrifice a good deal in order to
obtain the answer now I felt that I was
on the track of it Freud himself had a
neurosis no doubt diagnosable and one
would highly troublesome symptoms as I
discovered on our voyage to America of
course he had told me that everybody is
somewhat neurotic and that we must
practice tolerance but I was not at all
inclined to content myself with that
rather I wanted to know how one could
escape having a neurosis apparently
neither Freud nor his disciples could
understand what it meant for the theory
and practice of psychoanalysis if not
even the must I could deal with his own
neuroses when therefore Freud announced
his intention of identifying theory and
Method and making them into some kind of
dogma I could no longer collaborate with
him they remain no choice for me but to
withdraw when I was working on my book
about the libido and approaching the end
of the chapter the sacrifice I knew in
advance that its publication would cost
me my friendship with Freud for I plan
to sit down in it my own conception of
incest the decisive transformation of
the concept of libido and various other
ideas in which I differed from Freud the
knee incest signified a personal
complication only in the rarest cases
usually incest has a highly religious
aspect for which reason the incest theme
plays a decisive part in almost all
cosmogony x' and in numerous myths but
Freud clung to the literal
interpretation of it and could not grasp
the spiritual significance of incest as
a symbol I knew that he would never be
able to accept
any of my ideas on this subject should I
keep my thoughts to myself or should I
risk the loss of so important a
friendship at last I resolved to go
ahead with the writing and it did indeed
cost me Freud's friendship after the
break with Freud all my friends and
acquaintances dropped away my book was
declared to be rubbish I was a mystic
and that settled matter but I had
foreseen my isolation and harbored no
illusion about the reaction of my
so-called friends that was a point I had
thoroughly considered beforehand I had
known that everything was at stake but I
had to take a stand for my convictions I
realized the chapter the sacrifice meant
my own sacrifice having reached this
insight I was able to write again even
though I knew that my ideas would go
uncomprehending in retrospect I can say
that I alone logically pursued two
problems which most interested Freud the
problem of archaic vestiges and that of
sexuality it is a widespread error to
imagine that I do not see the value of
sexuality on the contrary it plays a
large part in my psychology as an
essential though not the sole expression
of psychic wholeness but my main concern
had been to investigate over and above
its personal significance and biological
function its spiritual aspect and its
numinous meaning and us to explain what
Freud was so fascinated by but was
unable to grasp sexuality is of the
greatest importance as the expression of
the chthonic spirit that spirit is the
other face of God the dark side of the
god image the question of the chthonic
spirit has occupied me ever since I
began to delve into the world of alchemy
basically this interest was awakened by
that early conversation with Froy
when mystified I felt how deeply stirred
he was by the phenomenon of sexuality
Freud's greatest achievement
probably consisted in taking neurotic
patients seriously and entering into
their peculiar individual psychology he
had the courage to let the case material
speak for itself and in this way was
able to penetrate into the real
psychology of his patients he saw with
the patient's eyes so to speak and so
reached a deeper understanding of mental
illness than had hitherto been possible
in this respect he was free of bias and
courageous has succeeded in overcoming a
host of prejudices like an Old Testament
prophet he undertook to overthrow false
gods to rip the veils away from a mass
of dishonest ease and hypocrisy
mercilessly exposing the rottenness of
the contemporary psyche he did not
falter in the face of the unpopularity
such an enterprise entailed the impetus
which he gave our civilization sprang
from his discovery of an avenue to the
unconscious by evaluating dreams as the
most important source of information
concerning the unconscious processes he
gave back to mankind a tool that had
seemed irretrievably lost he
demonstrated empirically the presence of
an unconscious psyche which had hitherto
existed only as a philosophical
postulate